scientists have discovered a
revolutionary new treatment that makes
you live longer it enhances your memory
and makes you more creative it makes you
look more attractive it makes you slim
and lowers your food cravings it
protects you from cancer and dementia it
wards off colds and the flu it lowers
your risk of heart attack stroke and not
to mention diabetes you'll feel happier
less depressed less anxious are you
interested if so
keep listening practically right now the
number one thing that actually does all
this stuff is sleep and sleep is a key
determinant in how good of sleep you are
physically how much fat you store and
where how good you are making decisions
how productive you are how intelligent
you are and in other words this isn't
the kind of stress that makes you
stronger it's the kind of stress that
makes you dumber fatter slower and with
a smaller bank account and if you don't
know who i am my name is alex mosey i am
the owner managing partner of
acquisition.com we have a portfolio of
companies about 85 million a year and i
have nothing to sell you and one of the
key questions i get a lot is what do you
do at night in order to have a nighttime
routine and so i have assembled a large
amount of habits over my life i think i
counted them over 55 that i'm going to
go with you and a lot of them are as
tiny as put you know take a piece of
salt before you go to bed so that you
don't pee at night like there's tiny
little hacks that i've developed over
time that i've acquired from learning
and i heavily ripped off this
presentation from the presentation that
i gave with dr trevor cashy my good
friend at one of our licensee meetings
and so without further ado i want to
explain to you why this is such an
important part of making money and that
might sound crazy to you but i will
explain and so the reasons for
entrepreneurs in terms of why we need to
have good sleep schedule good sleep
hygiene good sleep routines etc is
really two main things number one is
impulse control and number two is
intelligence so from an impulse control
perspective i'm sure you guys have
already heard a lot of self-development
books and know about the lizard brain
and all that kind of stuff um and as it
turns out a sleep deprived brain
basically has use has us performing as a
drunk person and so it gives us the
emotional stability of a drunk human
being and so the the fancy connection
between you being a lizard and the part
of your brain that says hey maybe we
shouldn't do that gets weaker and so
your ability to put on the brakes goes
down and so it doesn't inherently make
you a negative person but it makes you
more reactive and more prone to be
overreactive or emotional when you
ideally shouldn't be in a business
scenario second is intelligence so our
ability to learn new things the more you
sleep the more your brain clears out
useless information from short term and
stores it as useful information into the
long term so if you don't sleep as much
you'll have a goofy short-term memory
while you're on wake on top of a
terrible capacity to move information
from short-term to long-term while you
sleep not only that uh what you do to
manage to learn during a sleep-deprived
state erodes away each night so even if
you
get a regular time to sleep your ability
to store learn and recall information is
cut almost in half with as little as two
hours of sleep deprivation all right so
to drive this home your ability to learn
is even apparent with fitful sleep that
is to say sleeping enough but if your
sleep is poor quality you are still
doomed to be learning challenged and
this can mean anything from the ghost um
in other words if you don't sleep as
much or as well as you could be you're
dumber because of it and as a result
you'll make less money that's my case
now i didn't really like any of this
stuff in general because i'm not a big
believer in superstitions and whatnot
and i will cover some of my beliefs
around this topic but my first wake-up
call was when i actually had a client in
my first business uh i snapped at a
customer and she was like you can't do
that i realized what i had said and the
person had a very normal request and i
just like really bit their head off um
she's like you're not gonna be able to
run a business like this and that was
when i realized i needed to change some
stuff and so that kind of began the
journey for me down this 100 million
dollar sleep compendium of little tips
and tricks that have served me well over
55 that i will cover in this video now
that being said i broke this down into
kind of four major buckets um beliefs
around sleep that have served me well
the environment that is conducive to the
best high quality sleep three intake in
terms of all things you put into your
body or directly applied to your body
that have improved my ability to sleep
and then finally uh habits that surround
sleep and activity in general that i
generally um do and so i didn't really
think that i had so many of these until
i started to write them down for this
video because it was a question that i
was getting in my faqs on the gram and
so without further ado let's rock and
roll okay so here are my eight beliefs
around sleep number one is do not create
superstition all right so you have to
remove the have to must need to should
uh from like if i don't get eight hours
of sleep
right like if you if you think that way
so as much as i just said everything's
important i'm now gonna just contradict
myself in saying that i think that these
beliefs are more important than the rest
of the stuff i'm gonna cover this video
alright because the thing is is like
still think about this as an 80 20. like
if 80 percent of the time you're good
and 20 of the time you're not it happens
right we're human and everyone wants to
be perfect and no one is and then for
that reason we get upset with ourselves
that being said whenever you say things
like i have to i must i should you're
actually creating a threat to yourself
in the universe because the next thing
is or what like i have to get this sleep
comma or what right or i have to follow
my routine comma or what right and if
you fill out that or what all of a
sudden you realize that some of the
beliefs you have are kind of silly and
so one of the worst things you can do
after this presentation is a disclaimer
and a warning is take all of this all
the stuff i'm going to show you as
doctrine and say if i don't do all these
55 things i am a a terrible person i
will have terrible sleep i will make
less money and i will suck don't do that
all right if you can take one or two of
these things to improve your sleep on 10
of your nights of sleep for the year
it's a win right so look at it on 365
nights if we can by the end of this
video increase your quality of sleep by
10 or 20 just from
one 20 minute thing that you do one time
and consume it that is a amazing return
on time and attention all right so so
just as a big disclaimer number two as
much as i just said that sleep is so
important a belief that has served me
well is thinking i don't need a lot of
sleep now in doing that what it does is
that my anxiety around sleep is not
really present at all like i don't
obsess about sleep i have done all the
things that i'm going to cover in this
video and i do these things ahead of
time so i don't have to think about it
um but like i don't i don't allocate a
lot of time towards sleep stuff in
general especially a lot of mental
efforts a lot of people struggle with
sleeping and i understand that and i am
not one of them but i think part of it
is because of the 55 things i'm about to
show you which i have now covered two of
them now the the third point here is i
like to have the belief that i can sleep
anywhere right so we want to create our
sleep dojo right our our ideal scenarios
where we want to sleep but we want to
have the capacity the flexibility the
adaptability to be able to sleep on a
floor with nothing right and so it's
balancing these two ideas of like i want
to increase the likelihood of my my
success or ideal outcome while also in
no way needing to having to musting this
thing right i'm i don't have to do this
thing i prefer to do this thing all
right number four this is a belief that
has served me well ninety percent of the
benefit that you get of being asleep is
from being just in a dark room with your
eyes closed and so the reason you might
be like well i don't know if that's
sciencey hold on if you've ever been
tired in the middle of the day and you
just close your eyes for 10 minutes or
15 minutes then you feel completely like
regenerated or re-energized it's because
you get a lot of benefits just from
being in a dark room with your eyes
closed and so i have taken that as a
belief of mine because sometimes when
you have this anxiety of like i have to
fall asleep quickly i have to get more
hours i have to count down the clock
like all of those things decrease the
likelihood you're going to sleep and so
for me that's why i say i don't need a
lot of sleep i just remember that's 80
20. i don't have to be superstitious
about it i am the type of person that
can be successful and energized and
succeed even if i sleep i don't sleep at
all because i have a history and a past
i've known that i can do that and so it
decreases my need for having to sleep
which then in so doing actually allows
me to sleep more number five working all
day helps so so i i never really had any
issues sleeping but i especially didn't
have issues sleeping when i
was starting my first businesses because
i worked literally all day long and i
could sleep standing up and so if you
ever in these situations we are
struggling i do think that just
literally working harder doing more
stuff doing more thought consuming work
doing more physical activity helps and
so if you're not if you're not doing
that stuff maybe you can take a real ego
egoless look at yourself and say like
can i be working harder are the things
that i'm doing right now not engaging
and that could be in your work that can
be whatever and in so doing is it
impairing my sleep because i'm not
getting enough of a spike during the day
which is not creating enough of a trough
at night because the actual worst case
scenario of what it looks like to not
sleep well is that usually you're groggy
during the day and then you're groggy at
night but you're never fully asleep and
you're never fully awake so what you
want is the highest peaks during the day
and the lowest troughs at night and if
you're not getting the high peaks you
need to create the high peaks so that
you can give yourself the opportunity to
crash number six tracking i stopped
doing it so i used to track at one of
those rings or a band or whatever i
remember i've tried i've tried apps i've
tried different things but what ended up
happening in and i i'll tell you i
haven't solved this problem for me i get
i'm too competitive i'm competitive with
myself and i see and every day i wanted
to you know break a new sleep record but
you don't hit sleep records right like
but i am an incremental improver by
nature and so whenever i saw that stuff
i ended up thinking and obsessing and i
would try not to move at all because i
didn't want to move my phone which would
[ __ ] the app up um and so i i basically
threw out all the apps and i slept
better as a result because the end of
the day that's all that matters all
right number seven don't judge yourself
not good or bad as humans animals don't
need perfect sleep to survive think
about the amount of times the animals
have to move in the middle of the night
because the predator comes by like all
of these things are ideal they're we
don't have to be perfect and judging
ourselves is usually the source of the
vast majority of the anxiety that we
have is that we say we are bad sleepers
therefore i'm a bad person i i have i
don't have mental health that's great
blah blah blah which then you can ask
the question why do i need to have great
mental health right why is why does it
make me a bad person right and so you
can ask other questions around the
threats that you're
implying with your must have to
statements and then finally and this is
a belief that has served me while this
is kind of on the border of habit but it
felt better in this bucket treating
weekdays and weekends as the same thing
is one of the easiest and biggest things
that you can do in the beginning of your
kind of entrepreneurial career because
you probably work on weekends anyways so
they are probably your weekdays as much
they're just weekdays without meetings
and so you can actually just get more
work done and so for me my most
productive work actually happens on the
weekends and so that's when i want to
get my best sleep right and so i
definitely don't want to change the way
i sleep and when i wake up during those
times or treat them any differently okay
so without further ado that is the first
of the four buckets so beliefs are now
covered sorry i didn't put check marks
on this thing i figured you guys would
care more that i just cranked this out
for you those are the beliefs and that
is my big disclaimer before i dive into
this because people will love to say oh
my god if i don't do all these 50 things
i'm gonna suck and i don't want you to
do that take one or two of them take
three or four of them implement them
over time maybe one of these things is
like oh i didn't know i could do that
and awesome we'll do okay number one
make the room cold and if it looks like
it's small on the on the form on the
sheet here it's because i have a lot of
them on this list so here's nine
environment hacks all right these are
the things that you can do and this is
the nice thing about the environment
hacks you can do it once and then never
worry about it again like i love do it
once and then get benefits forever this
is one of these things so make sure that
you have good ventilation if you haven't
fixed your ac unit and it's not strong
enough if you haven't fixed the
insulation in the room fix it you'll
sleep better it is worth it no matter
how much money you make for the life
benefit you get because if you sleep
better you tend i'll give you an
interesting stat that i don't have in
the presentation one more hour of sleep
creates more happiness for the average
american than an extra 70 000 a year
okay
crazy so think about that like you can
try to make more money or you can just
sleep a little bit more right or a
little bit better so number one make the
room cold typical is 68 to 72 we sleep
at 67. i like it cold i run hot and i
tend to have like a sheet on and layla
has like two blankets all right so make
sure that the room is cold enough for
you if it's not it's just miserable
number two have a house plant in the
sleeping room everyone needs a friend
right something alive is nice now i'll
tell you at the very end of this little
nine part section all the things that i
do i do number one i don't do number two
and i'll explain at the end in a second
but number three get rid of all the
lights in the room aside from the
overhead lights obviously so don't do
the charging stuff leds anything of that
nature not even your phone in the
sleeping room all right so get out the
screens tv's computer get it out of the
room all right keep your phone in
another room if you can it will keep
your anxiety levels also a tad bit lower
because all of your anxiety comes from
your phone so if you can get it out of
the room getting out of the sleeping
area will help you from a headspace
perspective okay number four get
blackout curtains or eye mask or better
yet do both and you want to be able to
like it should be able to be pitch black
in the room in the middle of the day
like that's how isolated is like just
having curtains isn't good enough
because there's the things on the sides
and i'm telling you i know this sounds
minor but like the depth of your like
these are all you do this one time and
you just get better sleep forever so
like to me one-time fix for long-term
benefit worth it all right number five
and you know what as a side note a lot
of people don't do this stuff in their
businesses either it's like if you can
if you can front load the work and then
just get enduring compounding returns on
on the back end why not do it okay so
number five get a weighted blanket
anecdotal evidence suggests 10 of your
body weight so if you're 200 pounds get
a 20 pound blanket make sense there's
actually a ton of research that supports
this which is pretty cool it's rare that
like new stuff actually comes out that's
useful way to blankets pretty cool
number six get a nice mattress all right
i can give you the stats you know the
mattress salesman pitch but basically
you're spending eight hours of your day
right in bed it's like a third of your
day it's like we spend millions of
dollars on a house when you spend like a
grand on a mattress like come on it just
like it you don't even spend that much
time in your car like think about it i i
agree with the pitch and i think it
makes complete sense like there's not
many expenditures that will increase the
quality of your life and your
productivity so much as just getting a
mattress that isn't shitty number seven
this is a great one this is actually one
that i started we started doing like six
six or seven years ago and it's just
been really great and i used to make fun
of layla for it but now i actually
really like it having a white noise
machine or a white noise app on your
phone there's a zillion free ones or
getting used to ear plugs if you're used
to that because we right now like where
i'm at right now we're on the strip so
like i have plenty of noise and light
around me so we have blackout curtains
and we've got your earplugs if we need
them which i only really have to do on
like big concert nights because a white
noise machine covers all that and so
like if you and you and your partner you
make noise or you have have
all the little creaks and things that
wake you up in the middle of the night
all of that goes away with a white noise
machine so like for me this is one of
those things like if you get used to the
beginning because i didn't have it
lailey used to sleep with one and i
didn't and i started sleeping together
and so i had to get used to sleeping
with white noise but now that we do have
it it's actually awesome because when
you go to hotels when you're in
different areas and you have this thing
that you can't control from an
environmental perspective just having
white noise just blocks everything out
which is great all right you can even
have a fan and pointing against the wall
doesn't really matter eight um i have an
orthotic pillow so uh for me i have like
terrible neck [ __ ] and so i sleep with
an orthotic glow like wraps around my
back like a u it's like a 200 pillow
i'll see if i can put links in the in
the description from some of the stuff
that i reference but anyways getting a
good pillow is important so like try
them out and like here's here's a fun
one buy five if you're like i'm gonna
spend five
i'm gonna buy five pillows yes buy five
pillows figure out the one you like the
most and then toss the rest and you're
like what waste yes life is short sleep
on a good pillow all right number nine
sleeping buddies consider separate rooms
i know this is crazy and and absolutely
against common common whatever um layla
and i actually didn't sleep in the same
bedroom for like a year and a half and
it and believe it or not you can still
have sex if you don't sleep in the same
bed the same way you did before you were
married when you didn't sleep in the
same bed i know crazy and so uh you'll
also probably like each other more if
you're both sleeping a little bit better
but i actually used to have terrible
terrible trouble breathing i still kind
of do which is why i wear these patches
which cover in a second and so we did
that for a while i got my my sleep thing
fixed and this is one of those
trade-offs where like technically we
should continue to sleep in separate
bedrooms but life-wise layla prefers me
to be in bed with her and so that is
what we do all right so these are all
like i said these are not half twos
these are like would be nice if you can
do it as a one-time fix all right so
those are the nine environmental hacks
now you might be like well what do i
take from this i do all the stuff i just
mentioned except i don't have any plants
because i don't like life i want death
to stare me in the face every night
before i go to bed i just haven't gotten
around to it but there's plenty of
resources to suggest that's a good thing
i don't do the way to blanket right now
i think it's because we we moved and i
just didn't take the blanket with me
when i slept in my own bed i had a
weighted blanket it's just been kind of
annoying with layla because then it's
like it's just kind of a pain and i need
a heavier one than she does and so like
logistically for me it was a pain so
that's why i don't do it but i do it is
beneficial and it does help i think it
also makes you move less because it's
just heavy and so it kind of keeps you
more still which i think is helpful as
well uh we don't sleep in separate beds
because uh post neurosurgery like i
mentioned and i do have my phone in the
room all right but i don't have all the
other lights i do all the blackout stuff
all the cold stuff all the other things
i just said we do i do have my phone in
the room though but there are no like
alarm clock lights or anything else and
my phone is down against the thing and i
probably shouldn't do it but i haven't
had an issue sleeping so that goes to
show you that you can just get half the
[ __ ] right and still be fine okay so
beliefs and environment check check one
two going to number three which is
intake this one will be fun these are
all the things you get to do to your
body and imbibe yourself all right
number one if you have supplements and
things like that that you want to take
put it next to your bed or buy your
toothbrush it's the easiest way that i
have found to not have to forget this
stuff because i am inherently i tend to
be a forgetful person all right all
right i just don't remember things as
frequently as i probably should okay so
i use sleep multipliers product by
prestige labs i probably should have a
link or logo i used to own majority of
the company i still continue to take the
product it's exceptional if you are the
type of person who tracks it take it for
30 days and look at your sleep source
before and after and for everyone it's
not a sedative all right you're not
gonna like immediately take it and just
like pass out but what you will notice
is that your average sleep scores on a
30-day rolling period will be better i
guarantee it all right like i said i
don't know i'm not the majority of the
governor of the company so i could say
that but uh it is expensive but it is
100 worth it it is so so so worth it um
like what do you pay for increas like
people buy courses they buy all these
things when you could spend like three
bucks a day and have 20 increased output
because you sleep better like to me it's
not even a question okay let's get to
the things that we're gonna try and help
prevent from things that fragment sleep
so peeing a lot of people get up in the
middle of night one two three times to
pee so here is where we can actually nip
this in the butt i used to do this so
like let me help number one you can take
salt tabs before you go to bed all right
so if you take if you have salt tabs
next to your bed you can take them and i
drink it with gatorade zero rather than
water because there's salt in there as
well and what it happens is you it
constricts the amount of water you like
you bloat right but the thing is is like
don't worry like if you get on a cycle
you'll pee it out you're not gonna look
bloated all right but what happens is it
it will restrict the amount that you'll
pee for a short period of time all right
and so you might actually be able to
make it through the night without having
to pee if you take the extra salt all
right that's kind of the idea i already
said the gatorade water and as a side
note and this is something that i've
just developed over time is like i eat
at the same time every day so i eat my
breakfast the same time i eat lunch at
the same time i eat dinner at the same
time and the more you can get in that
habit the more regular your digestion
gets the more regular bowel movements
get but also as a result of that you
have less
less variety
which comes down to you sleep better
because there's less like kind of
variables that are affecting your sleep
right so if you have anyone's had like
crazy indigestion because you had really
hot tie one night and you had it two
hours later than you normally do you're
not probably not gonna sleep as well and
that's just like is this tie really
worth that i don't know maybe it is
maybe it's not but if it like sets you
back like a day or two because you
didn't sleep that well to me it's not
really worth the thai food all right now
breathing and this one is a special
section for me because i have struggled
with this a ton my whole life since i
was in eighth grade i couldn't read that
well so there's there's there's three
main things that come to breathing so
i'm gonna go a little bit on a tangent
here because i've done a lot of work and
spend a lot of money on this stuff there
is your allergies so your level of
congestion there's the the shape of your
nostrils right and there's the stuff
that's inside of it so you have like the
shape of your nostrils if you have
things that are impeding it and then you
have congestion all right so those are
kind of like the three variables and so
if you have i'm forgetting the the name
there are the things that they're like
these globules i can't remember the name
inside um of your of your of your of
your sinus and your nasal cap cavity if
you can get those removed surgically
which you can it'll improve your
breathing i don't know why this guy got
all zoomy let's see if we can get back
here we go and the easiest thing like
besides doing the surgeries and whatnot
that you can do is i'm going to cover in
this little breathing thing okay no
strips number one absolute lifesaver
they're awesome you can look on amazon
go grab whatever i'll have the links the
ones that i use like the reason i wear
these is because i sleep in them and i
continue to breathe great in them and
that's why i do it and when i couldn't
breathe at all this is the only way i
could sleep and when i after the surgery
i went from being able to sleep okay and
fine-ish without them and now i just
sleep even better with it now i'll give
you a hack that i don't have listed here
that if you don't have these or like
let's say you go out and you travel and
you forgot them or whatever i'm telling
like i've been doing this for years so
if you fall asleep you can fall asleep
on your hand like this and so what
happens is
like you don't have to you're not
actively pulling something but your
thumb is always going to be straight
right and so if you fall asleep like
this it actually will keep one of your
nostrils open like that's how i had to
sleep for like 10 years before i found
out about these strips all right highly
recommend next thing creams and sprays
so like there are there are nasal sprays
i think salt sprays work i don't like
doing any kind of drugs and medication
stuff because i don't like to be
dependent on anything but if you have
those things put those beside your bed
like i said solid sprays work well and i
actually put cream on my face when i
remember to uh so that hopefully i don't
look old and gray in a year
peppermint oil stuff uh i think i just
put it on top of my mustache if you put
it too close inside the rim it starts to
burn so i just put it like right on my
on my stash on my upper lip and that
seems to work okay for me and i only use
that now in like extreme situations i
don't normally and then neti pots for
people who um like that thing uh work
well for people from a breathing
perspective but for me the big one is
the nasal strips and how i sleep for
breathing okay now those are the things
that you can start doing but you're like
man alex it sounds like a lot of stuff
to start doing well let me tell you
things you can stop doing number one and
this is a huge one especially with
entrepreneurs we love the stims i get it
but try and cut it after 10 a.m so like
sorry like don't don't drink them after
10. uh it will affect your sleep people
like oh i can drink a zillion things of
caffeine and pass right out it means
that you are completely like
it means that you're not receptive to
them anymore which means you're like not
getting the adrenal boost that you want
from it and you have become sensitized
to it because you have such rolling
amounts of caffeine in your system at
all times that you never even get it out
all right so you have to you have to you
have to pull the plug on this because
the half-life of caffeine is six hours
half-life so let's say you take a gram
of caffeine that's a thousand milligrams
it's a lot of caffeine six hours later
you have 500 that's still a lot of
caffeine six hours later you have 250.
still a lot of caffeine that's two
coffee cups six hours later right you
have 120 which is one cup of coffee but
now we've already done half life
six six so there's four sixes it's 24
hours we already covered a day and you
still have a cup of coffee in your
system so you have to think about the
half-life of the thing that you're
drinking so if you drink a cup of coffee
in the morning 12 hours later it'll be
it'll be at a quarter of what you were
so if you had 120 if you have 30
milligrams of caffeine still in your
system all right 12 hours later and if
you're sleeping 18 hours later which you
should be right i should using loosely
here for ideal sleep scenarios that
means that you're now at 15 milligrams
which for most people would be okay and
so that's why how much you take
throughout the day even the timing thing
like if you take a gram in the morning
it will affect your sleep at night
because the half-life is still like
taking 500 milligrams six hours later
think about this when you're when you're
when you're thinking about stimulants
all together if you're if you're one of
those people's trouble sleeping i would
say i would suggest try not to do it and
suffer for the five days and then
restart you know re-kick start your your
sleeping habits all right number two
have your last meal two hours before bed
i cover this with a peeing thing but
like just don't if you eat right before
bed you'll usually have to do some more
bowel stuff or pee or whatever and it
also can affect your digestion it can
increase your body temperature all those
things if you do it right before bed
number three stop drinking out within
four hours of bed so ideally if you're
gonna drink do do it as a day party
rather than going late into the night
and as a side note you actually end up
being more hungover from the fact that
you [ __ ] up your sleep more than the
alcohol anyways but as a side note
there's tons of stuff on alcohol you
probably already know that but just as a
reminder and then stop drinking liquids
throughout before going to bed right uh
like if you do that then you can ideally
you front load all your drinking in the
morning so when you wake up drink a
bunch of water and then that way you
drink less over the day and you pee more
so your balance between drinking and
peeing drink a lot more than you pee in
the beginning of the day and then you
drink less and less and less and pee
throughout the end of the day so that
overnight you wake up and then you're
really thirsty and then you do it again
right you don't want us to flip that
habit where you drink a ton right before
you go to bed and then you're peeing all
while you're trying to sleep and then
you wake up and then you don't drink
right so just flip the flip the cycle
and the nice thing is you start once you
start doing this once it's very easy to
stick with because your body will just
do it naturally number five avoid
medicines that delay or disrupt your
sleep alright so um a lot of these
different things can disruptively
pattern so like that's why i don't like
taking antihistamine things or things i
just don't like taking meds in general
on a regular basis before bed this is
not medical advice i'm not a medical
doctor all the stuff you already know
i'm saying these are things that have
worked well for me and i try not to
become dependent on anything my two
cents i do everything that i just
mentioned except i only have the mentor
for extreme circumstances and i don't
use a nutty pot because i hate it and it
burns my nose and i'm a [ __ ] about it
okay
that's that
go so beliefs environment intake check
check check number four is the habits
all right so there are 13 habits that
we're going to cover and let's rock and
roll with them so number one i should
have made these uh as step wise but i
guess i left this whole list out um a.m
sleep at least 20 minutes preferably 30
minutes get an hour of total sunlight
during the day if you can and i think
this is great for a work break thing
like after you eat lunch go walk right
it's an easy thing to do go walk and
talk take phone calls whatever it works
take a short walk before bed i like this
room i usually walk after i eat so just
fyi after i launch after i dinner i walk
and that's kind of my jam and so that's
an easy way to implement this from a
workout perspective don't work out two
hours before you go to bed because your
body temperature stays elevated for up
to two hours so don't do that or you
will mess up your sleep screen's off
this is just a general reminder yet
again from a habit perspective all right
two hours before bed now i'll tell you
the stuff that i do versus don't do in
these habits but these are the things
that generally i have collected over my
years as things that have helped me
sleep better so i can make more dollars
number five go to bed between nine and
eleven set an alarm so here's a common
one that people don't do is that people
love to have wake up alarms but they
don't have to go to bed alarms you
should go to bed alarm and not go a wake
up alarm if you have the right go to bed
alarm you will wake up naturally at the
time that you should wake up i know
crazy and so if you need more sleep
you'll sleep more and i mean less sleep
you'll sleep less right beautiful thing
about the body all right and as a side
note with napping and i'm a fan i am
somebody who likes to nap it's fine try
not to nap after two o'clock and try not
to nap for longer than 30 minutes
because all my stuff up so for me i set
my timer at 20 and i know that i go into
the the thing with the mindset that if i
don't fall asleep at all and i have my
eyes closed in a dark room for for 20
minutes i get 90 of the benefits without
even having to go to sleep which
actually ends up decreasing my anxiety
around the sleeping overall and then i
end up actually falling asleep in like
five seconds the next seven and i
probably should have gotten the numbers
to start at eight but so be it if you
can sleeping on your back is much better
uh from uh from like uh not messing up
your shoulders and stuff especially if
you're a bigger guy it's like
side and back are better than than front
because you're all like splayed out so
like i said i try and use my hand to
keep my nose open if we're just talking
about sleeping positions and then slide
the face off the side of the pillow so
you can tilt your pillow so it like
smashes your face like this and you can
breathe better sleeping naked for
comfort and temperature that should be
self it also helps with number three
which is only sleep insects in the
sleeping room eat in the eating rooms
work in the working rooms ideally you
can separate the types of activities
that you're doing in the room because
you will carry over the anxiety of the
activities that you do in that room they
will anchor the room for you now you're
like what if i go in a hotel and i work
and i sleep in a [ __ ] and i eat all in
the same hotel room short term long term
80 20. if you're doing it for the short
term it happens it's okay don't worry
about it but like long term if we're
gonna make a habit so that we can
increase our overall effectiveness then
it's worth doing all right or or
delineating excuse me if you can have an
orgasm before bed sleeping naked helps
doing that too and it does improve your
quality of sleep which is great which
for so have a partner with you right go
orgasm together play with friend all
right number five taking a hot shower or
a bath before bed decreases internal
body temperature when you get out of it
you'll fall asleep faster because the
decrease in core temperature induces
sleep makes sense right cool meditate
for a few minutes i don't do this i'm
going to cover all the stuff that i do
in a second but for some people they
like it a lot so do it and try and
unwind before you sleep like if you've
got something you can do if you read a
book whatever i don't think that working
all the way until the moment you sleep
is good for me personally i pretty much
stop working after dinner so i work
until dinner and then that's after i eat
i'm pretty much done so just people ask
me all the time so that's the answer all
right and so um everything that i just
said i do except for the screens off
thing i'm not perfect and um i don't do
the the hot shower before bed or the
meditation either and that is uh because
i haven't had any issues with sleeping
but if you are one of these people like
do more of that stuff and then you can
start removing the things that are like
have the lower input for you right
bottom line if you're an entrepreneur
and you're trying to make more dollars
and you want to have lower emotional
reactivity when you have a higher
quality of decisions higher intelligence
higher ability to learn less more
adaptability in general sleeping is
important the beliefs that i shared at
the beginning of the things that have
served me well these environmental
traits the intake differences and the
habits that i mentioned are the things
that have served me well and i wanted to
put them all in one video so that i
would never have to answer the question
again besides saying watch this video
this covers everything that i know about
sleeping that i do in my real life for
everyone else
go to sleep or watch the next video and
like i said mossy nation love you guys
and i'll see you soon bye